artificial intelligence has been gaining
popularity in recent years from robots
serving food and restaurants to
self-driving cars these artificial
intelligence applications can be seen in
our day-to-day lives while professionals
across the globe are worried about
robots replacing humans a Gartner study
reports that AI is an emerging field
that will create 2.8 million jobs by the
year
2025 so AI is a broad term encompassing
General artificial intelligence machine
learning export systems Data Mining and
in today's world AI capabilities are in
high demand across Industries gaming
robotics face recognition software
Weaponry speech recognition Vision
recognition expert systems and search
engines consequently the compensation
packages for AI Engineers have been
notably attractive according to glaso
the average salary of an AI engineer is
$160,000 in the United States States and
in India it's 11 lakh rupees per enom
serving as a significant incentive for
individuals venturing into this domain
the top companies hiring AI Engineers
worldwide are Amazon Netflix Microsoft
IBM and Nvidia so if you are evaluating
career options in this emerging AI field
look at these top 10 jobs in artificial
intelligence and the skills that you
will need to transition into these routs
but before we move on if you love
watching these type of videos consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
press the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from simply also accelerate your
career in Ai and machine learning with a
comprehensive post-graduate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning boost your career with this a
ml course delivered in collaboration
with the p University and IB learn in
demand skills such as machine learning
deep learning NLP computer vision
reinforcement learning generative AI
prompt engineering chat GPT and menu you
will receive a prestigious certificate
and ask me anything sessions by IBM with
five capston in different domains using
real data sets you will gain practical
experience master classes by purd
faculty and IBM experts ensure topnotch
education simply learns job assist help
you get notified by Leading companies
this program covers statistics python
supervised and unsupervised learning NLP
neural networks computer vision G Keras
tensorflow and many more skills
admission to this postgraduate program
in AI machine learning course requires
two plus years of work experience a
bachelor's degree with an average of 50%
or higher marks and basic understanding
of programming Concepts and Mathematics
so enroll now and unlock Ai and machine
learning opportunities the link is
mentioned in the description box below
so without any further delay let's hand
over this session to our training expert
AI roles are evolving rapidly mirroring
the rapid advancement in technology here
are some of the leading AI position
worth exploring the first one is AI
product manager an AI product manager is
much like other program managers they
oversee teams for AI product development
handling schedules and
Milestones to do this effectively they
need understand AI components like
hardware and programming languages which
helps them support their teams creating
AI apps defers from web apps
infrastructures and development
processes consequently the compensation
packages for AI product managers have
become notably attractive according to
glass door the average salary of an AI
product manager is around
$190,000 in the US and in India it is 26
lakhs perom serving as a significant
incentive for individuals venturing into
this domain moving forward let's see
second one AI research scientist AI
research scientist often computer
scientists focusing on innovating AI
algorithms and models their duties
includes creating and evaluting in new
AI models collab collaborating in
research publishing papers and
presenting at the conferences while
programming is the part of their work
it's just a portion unlike the tech
industry opens to selft Talked
programmers AI research scientists need
strong backgrounds in computer science
mathematics and strategy consequently
the compensation packages for AI
research scientists have become notedly
attractive according to glass door the
average salary of an AI research
scientist is
$125,000 in the US and in India it's 21
lakh perm serving as a significant
incentive for individuals venturing into
this domain the third one is ml engineer
a machine learning Engineers creates and
deploys training algorithms and models
which is the most demanding part of
machine learning most of machine
learning engineer holds Advanced degrees
in computer science mathematics or
statistics due to the need for advanced
math skills many also pursue a
specialized master degree or
certification in machine learning deep
learning or neural network
consequently the compensation packages
for machine learning Engineers have
become notably attractive according to
glass door the average salary of an ml
engineer is
$150,000 in the US and in India it's 11
lakh perom serving as a significant
incentive for individuals venturing into
this domain the next on the list is Big
Data engineer Ai and Big Data both deal
with large data sets a big data engineer
like an AI engineer designs test and
maintains complex data system for
substantial data set but their focuses
in On Tools like Haro Hive spark and
Kafka like AI researchers Big Data
Engineers often have advanced degree in
math and Statics which are crucial for
managing extensive data pipelines
consequently the compensation packages
for Big Data Engineers have become
notably active according to glaso the
average salary of Big Data engineer is
$120,000 in the US and in India it's 8.5
lakh perom serving as a significant
incentive for individuals venturing into
this domain the fifth one is NLP
engineer a natural processing engineer a
computer scientist specializes in
algorithms and system for understanding
and processing human language in its
natural form unlike traditional search
engine that rely on keywords and data
aggregation generative AI interfaces
like chat GPT generate new content from
patterns and examples engaging in
conversation NLP Engineers like machine
learning Engineers May not necessarily
have a programming background as their
primary skills they need expertise in
linguistics alongside programming
knowledge for tasks like machine
translation text summarization question
answering and context comprehension
consequently the compensation package
for NLP Engineers have become notably
attractive according to glass door the
average salary of an NLP engineer is
$120,000 in the US and in India it's 10
lakh perom moving forward let's see bi
developer business intelligence
developer business intelligence predates
modern Ai and relies on extensive data
set bi developer use data analytics
platform reporting tools and
visualization to turn raw data into
valuable insight for informed decision
making they work with coding languages
like SQL python as well as the tools
such as W and powerbi understanding
business operations and crucial for
enhancing them through data driven ins
consequently the compensation package
for bi developers have become notably
activated according to glaso the average
salary of bi developer is $110,000 in
the US and in India it's 7 lakh per
moving forward we have computer vision
engineer a computer vision engineer is a
programmer skilled in creating software
using visual input sensors and algorithm
these systems can interpret their
environment as seen in self-driving cars
and facial recognition computer vision
engineer use languages like C++ and
python they work on the tasks like
object detection image segmentation
facial and gesture recognition and seen
comprehension the compensation package
for computer Visions Engineers are the
average salary of a computer vision
engineer is
$155,000 in the US and in India it's 8
lakh perom moving forwards let's see
data a data scientist is a tech expert
who analyze data to recognize
organization decision while some code
it's not always required they use data
mining Big Data techniques and analytics
data centers use inside to improve sales
streamline operation and make decisions
and innovate consequently the
compensation package for data senses
have become notably attractive according
to glass door the average salary of an
data scientist is
$150,000 in the US and in India it's 12
lakh perom serving as a significant
incentive for individuals venturing into
this domain the next one is Rob robotics
engineer a robotics engineer is a
software developer who creates and
improves software for robot control
robotics has seen recent advances like
automated home cleaners and precise
surgical robots these Engineers often
use Ai and machine learning to enhance
robot performance their work focuses on
software d by sensory input requiring
careful debugging of software and
hardware for streamline operations the
compensation package for robotics
engineers are according to glasso the
average salue of a robotics engineer ER
is $15,000 in the US and in India it's 6
lakh perom at the last we have software
Engineers software Engineers handle task
from design to development but it's rare
to find expertise in all phes they
usually specialize in specific areas the
specialization applies to AI software
Engineers too they work on various
application including machine learning
inference learning NLP and intrusion
deduction covering different aspects of
AI development consequently the
compensation package for software
Engineers becoming not attractive
according to glass door the average
salary of a software engineer is
$140,000 in the US and with that we have
come to end of this video on top 10 AI
job for 2024 I hope you found it
valuable and entertaining please ask any
question about this topics covered in
this video in the comment section below
our experts will assist you in
addressing your problem thank you for
watching stay safe and keep learning
with simply learn stay ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here